qu'on doit écouter la présidente de la
commission ont reçu la faune der leyen
qui s'exprime en ce moment on l'écoutait
états unis le royaume uni
et également le japon et d'autres
nous allons limiter
l'accès aux marchés des capitaux pour la
russie et ses sanctions auront un impact
lourd l'économie russe fait déjà face à
une pression énorme aux chevilles de
semaine et cette question sera apte
russe c'est sanctions auront un impact
fort sur la croissance économique russe
rencontrons l'inflation augmenteront
également la réduction des flux de
capitaux
la sanction ensuite permettra également
de limiter l'accès de la russie à des
technologies sociales nous souhaitons
fermer l'accès à la russie aux
technologies dont elle a besoin
aujourd'hui pour bâtir l'avenir
nos mesures s'affaibliront la position
technologique de la russie dans des
domaines clés en particulier les
domaines dans lesquels l'élite russe
gagner plus d'argent nous ciblerons
notamment les secteurs des logiciels
et tout cela aura un impact dommageable
fort sur l'économie russe à l'avenir
permettez-moi d'être très clair ce sera
au président poutine d'expliquer tout
cela ses propres citoyens je sais que le
peuple russe ne souhaite pas de cette
bière l'union européenne et l'otan
travaillent en étroite collaboration et
cette crise nous rassemblerons un encore
plus notre devoir partager et de
ceux de
contrer de manière unie à cette
agression sur le sol européen notre
unité et notre plus grande force le
russie a tenté de nous affaiblir et de
nous désunir mais ils ont
échoué nous sommes plus unis plus
déterminé que jamais ne s'amuse une
seule à lyon une jeune seule union une
seule alliance déterminée et unie
le sony dernière cataclysme a eu lieu en
europe d'une agression violente flagrant
de la part de la demi-heure poutine
négation faire des êtres humains
une attaque militaire deux grandes
échelles envers le peuple il ya cette
attaque non provoquée et non justifiés
ne ressemble à
rien de ce qui s'est passé en europe
depuis la fin d'un succès inédit depuis
1945 c'est une attaque envers le
territoire ukrainien son intégrité
territoriale sa souveraineté c'est une
violation flagrante du droit
international de l'état de droit qui a
été remplacé par la brutalité sont une
attaque envers la paix et la sécurité en
europe c'est également une attaque
envers les fondements de notre union
européenne c'est-à-dire notre projet de
paix de prospérité pour tous les
européens
l'union européenne et ses états membres
main dans la main avec nos alliés
demanderont à la russie de rendre des
comptes le conseil européen sera
convoquée aujourd'hui et conviendra en
principe d'un train de sanctions à
cibler et massive nous conviendrons
également
d'une aide politique financière et
humanitaire envers l'ukraine et son
peuple les civils du kenya ont été
frappés et b innocents ont été tués des
femmes des hommes des enfants fuient
pour protéger leur ville ils ont besoin
de notre appui aujourd'hui plus que
jamais nous avons également discuté des
implications géopolitiques économiques
et humaines de cette agression envers
l'ukraine et je ne pense pas que le
peuple russe souhaite la guerre
vous ne souhaitez pas en russie perdre
la vie de jeune homme pour une guerre
sans intérêt qui n'a aucun sens
aussi ne pourra pas continuer à
justifier cette guerre à 100 ces gens
demandent gens nagent un appel au peuple
russe vous avez le choix de ne pas
suivre ces actions destructrices vous
avez le choix de ne pas participer à
cette stratégie cette tragédie sans nom
et insensé envers le peuple kényan nous
sommes unis unis nous sommes
faire ensemble avec
l'otan en son ensemble avec nos amis
ensemble avec nos partenaires nos alliés
pour heavy rain et pour protéger la paix
en europe nous sommes solides et avec
tous les pays de ce monde qui souhaitent
protéger l'ordre international fondé sur
des règles au nom de la paix merci
charles michel ursula von der leyen aux
côtés du secrétaire général de l'otan
viennent james stoltenberg
charles michel parle de cataclysme en
europe la présidente de la commission
européenne dit que la stabilité en
europe est menacée il y aura un sommet
des 27
ce soir à 20 heures avec de nouvelles
sanctions on est toujours dans les
grandes déclarations là bruno oui alors
on est dans les grandes déclarations la
seule chose un peu concrète c'est il ya
deux choses en fait un peu concrète
c'est les sanctions économiques ciblées
massive donc la deuxième vague qui vont
être
dévoilée donc oui ça c'est une réponse
qui peut pas y avoir de réponse
militaire donc il ya cette réponse là et
puis une aide politique financière
humanitaire à l'ukraine comme vient de
le dire charles michel certains pays
aussi au sein de l'union européenne
estiment que l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne devrait être accéléré
enfin on voit bien que les deux
calendriers ne vont pas au même rythme
si on accélère une demande d'adhésion de
kiev à l'union européenne ça prend quand
même des semaines et des mois même en
accélérant pendant ce temps vladimir
poutine lui faire rouler ses chars vers
kiev notamment avec la question quand
même ce matin qu'est ce qu'il veut faire
exactement maintenant en ukraine est-ce
que c'est comme il dit une opération
spéciale pour aller dézinguer passez moi
l'expression
ce qu'il appelle les nazis de d'édifier
voilà quand il a appris ce matin
démilitarisé et des nazis fier il y
avait un objectif militaire qui était
d'exiger que l'armée me dit que l'armée
ukrainienne soit totalement désarmés
face à sur la neutralité de l'ukraine
c'est clair et puis des nazis fier ça
veut dire qu'ils estiment que le
président hélène ce qui est son
gouvernement légitimement élu et
largement élu démocratiquement et bien
c'est une junte en fait composé de nazis
donc là on est dans un monde parallèle
le monde parallèle de de vladimir
poutine et que donc le génocide océans
oui alors il parle de génocide de
l'armée craignant contenant les deux
républiques autoproclamées lui dans de
base pour justifier en fait
et donc en fait objectif militaire
objectifs politiques si on comprend bien
c'est d'aller à kiev pour dégager le
gouvernement ukrainien et le président
evans qui est installée parce qu'il en
reste en ukraine des pro russe une
occupation sur le long terme ça paraît
plus compliqué parce que notamment dans
tout l'ouest de l'ukraine il ya quand
même des millions d'ukrainiens qui n'ont
pas envie de se retrouver sous la férule
russe donc il y aura des formes de
résistance y compris des formes de
résistance civile avec deux cent mille
hommes c'est quand même très compliqué
de tenir un pays comme l'ukraine qui est
plus grand que la france un peu comme
ces six cent mille kilomètres carrés
donc ça paraît extrêmement compliqué
mais on ne sait jamais maintenant et
vladimir poutine puisque vous savez
quand ce genre de
huy de
dôme autoritaire on va dire par
dictateur dictateur selon boris johnson
par
danser logique là c'est logique de
guerre comme dit le président mitterrand
on ne sait pas où ça s'arrêtait
maintenant il y est il y est
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bras il
est bien il y est bien enfoncer donc il
est parti là dedans c'est difficile
aussi d'arrêter une armée qui est parti
en mouvement il faudra beaucoup de
discipline c'est vraiment son objectif
c'est de viser les bâtiments militaires
et civils stratégique des autorités
ukrainiennes
on voit qu'il ya déjà eu des victimes
civiles quand même hein nous disaient
nos nos envoyés spéciaux sur place ou
s'il envisage une plus grande occupation
de l'ukraine où quelqu'un ça prendra
encore une autre une autre forme bon
roselyne on revient quand même vers vous
et on termine cette parenthèse sur
l'élection présidentielle parce que
c'est important on est à 50 jours du
premier tour à moins de 50 jours du
premier tour la campagne continue et il
y à ses déclarations d'eric zemmour de
valérie pécresse de marine le pen qui
n'ont pas vu le danger finalement russe
oui et surtout les trois cd rom jean luc
mélenchon eric zemmour et marine le pen
notamment eric zemmour qui disait l'art
et la russie n'envahira jamais l'ukraine
il ya quelques jours encore donc quelque
part ça devient décrédibiliser ces trois
personnages qui d'ailleurs étaient ces
trois personnages de en tout cas marine
le pen eric zemmour qui sont
susceptibles d'être présent au second
tour d'anglas cesser des crimes
utilisation totale et ça peut les
affaiblir ça oui je pense je pense alors
aujourd'hui il rentre dans le rang on a
entendu jean luc mélenchon qui dit que
poutine est là le traité d'agresseurs
voilà
eric zemmour qui demandent l'arrêt des
hostilités oui
critiquer d'ailleurs le fameux raid bri
diplomatique lorsqu'il est allé à moscou
et à kiev de demandes en réalité de de
refaire ce chemin qui ne sert plus grand
chose aujourd'hui alors que la
diplomatie continue bien évidemment mais
là on est au delà de la diplomatie
maintenant ce sont les sanctions donc ce
qui va se passer c'est que à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui le président qu'on
poussait à être candidat en vérité est
bien va rester dans son rôle de
président et il rentrera dans le rôle du
candidat au dernier moment c'est-à-dire
le quatre-mâts ce qui est la clôture par
le conseil constitutionnel des
candidatures et il va chez fait jusqu'au
bout et personne ne va le reprocher donc
j'ai envie de dire emmanuel macron qui a
toujours dit qu'il y avait il dans ses
discours et dit toujours le tragique de
l'histoire et un moment il avait il
avait dit une phrase qui m'avait
d'ailleurs interpellé il avait dit ce
qui me rend optimiste c'est que
l'histoire devient tragique une phrase
assez une sorte d'oxymore en quelque
sorte et comme s'il avait la prescience
que l'histoire était effectivement
tragique comme s'il était là pour je ne
sais pas comme s'il avait quelque chose
aussi de d'une mission puisqu'il l'a
toujours évoqué cette idée de tragique
et aujourd'hui cette position qu'il a
d'un président dans l'histoire tragique
et bien ça va sans doute renforcer sa
posture
on va dire que jupiter yens en tout cas
d'hommes de deux présidents
le chef de guerre et les français vont
plus risque risque en tout cas avant
l'élection de se tourner vers lui
puisque c'est lui qu'on va écouter de
manière solennelle il a dit
vous avez de quoi vous inquiéter ou pas
à cause de lait des prix de l'énergie
évidemment puisque c'est quand même la
priorité des français quand on voit
c'est le pouvoir d'achat donc tout ce
qui est lié à l'énergie bien évidemment
et ça c'est la grande crainte du
président de la république puisque le
pouvoir d'achat et les nerfs et le prix
de l'énergie est un sujet hautement
inflammable si je puis me permettre ce
jeune macron très actif dans le dossier
ukrainien il ya eu ces allers retours
entre kiev et moscou ces nombreux coups
de fil à volodimir zelensky et à
vladimir poutine il a tenu un conseil de
défense ce matin l'elysée on a entendu
son compte rendu il demande une réunion
urgente de l'otan qui aura lieu demain
il doit participer le président une
visioconférence du g7 dans l'après midi
avant de se rendre à bruxelles donc pour
ce sommet extraordinaire des dirigeants
de l'union européenne à 20h merci